I'm talking to mr. Has he
very. I'm talking to mr.
Harry vizier who worked on the
sydney harbour bridge as a. As
a catcher didn't you as
a catcher. That was catch
in the rivets from the fire
into kerosene taking how far
could you catch them from
ah. Sometimes you know
it's happening here and at
a time. Turner ground only perhaps
twelve twenty feet and you.
He was catching all the time not throwing
at all. You know now and again you know
there's the cocaine on the furnace like.
And this was in the workshops was it shops
or shins point do you remember any incidents
while you were working there you know
nothing serious. And it went up. I
went no in-between to this
painting. We've laid and no
one block and it is out there to
the abbot and the handle broken
a lot. You got red led and when i
got home course i was covered.
But
a serious accident. With all the right.
Where did you live then i lived in
fitzroy street just only five minutes away
from it at no on the north side you know
so yeah. And when did you get the
job there on the bridge when.
About 1927. Friend at the strip
in which i was married then
and some friends. I got
out of a former rep.
David we met him recently still alive. I
haven't seen him for years now. I think
once after the war but i haven't seen him
since. We'll see him on friday. I hope
he'll be there. I've seen him. You have
seen him. That's good. You'll see him
do you remember any accidents while you
were working there you know in the shops it
was no serious accidents i can recall where
did you come from originally. I come
from london and how did you get out here
working on the boats and i paid for out
here. It paid off and
nation around two or three
places and both work and paid off. And
i got to know. David and
dave gray as another
maker steve over and cousin
and i got yes and i got me
a job with them. Was it
hard work in those days
it wasn't hard work. It was flat out
it all depends on the repeater the
joke statements and i think
his name was. And scotchman
and i used to go flat out and that and
of course it went to arguments. It was
a bit slow. If the river. Got too cold and
i could knock it down. Where you working
on the hydraulic rivers or the
pneumatic rubicon. I drive like
it's a big horseshoe
gantry was it are now in
a hangar and pike on hand. The
compressed air ones. Yes compressed air
and do you remember use that to keep flatten
out although did you know you. Brakes
and that when they shifted the job but
eventually it was all assembled in
a workshop you had so many
people into. And that when they came
without a crane to shift you had
a break. Understand. Do you remember getting
burned at all with the flying rivets.
Now that an ever got burnt
so we say shoot with
a good cone collapse and that and sometimes
to the tune it get hot. You know.
And what sort of tongs
did you pull it out with
a pair. I don't know but it could rip it
tongs and that the pieces are bent and you
picked it up say you put it in the
hole and then i read it down.
Do you remember anything or any of the
amusing incidents in the workshops while you
were there. You know there's
those days you never read
amusement. So anything. It was flat out
working and that there was no loud ups.
Like there is pressure today. How long
were you working in the workshops the
three or four years. And what was paid off
before the break loose.